pas mal de bazar aujourd'hui j'ai été
sélectionné je sais pas si vous savez il
ya quelques mois pour être ambassadeur
de google l'est google a choisi merci
google c'est très cool parce que j'aime
bien les produits et les services google
est aujourd'hui google est de retour
avec un tout nouveau produit que je
viens vous présenter en reste dans
google n'est ce donc on reste dans la
partie audio de google dans la maison
connectée bien évidemment avec
aujourd'hui nest audio alors on est
odieuse qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
l'ouvrir on va découvrir ce que c'est on
va découvrir les visages on va voir les
intérêts pourquoi est ce que vous
pourriez aller acheter découvrir la
google nest audio surtout qu'est-ce que
ça va venir vous apporter à la base tout
était dans cette boîte l'a alors
regardez gelé ouverte à votre service et
très sympathique gelé ouverte il y avait
ses petites lettres à l'intérieur et en
dessous vous avez gagné à qui tout le
temps il y avait ces petites bêtes là
nous a mis sur le côté alors ces boîtes
là elles contiennent les enceintes y en
a une chacune il y en a deux en fait
c'est la fameuse enceinte google nest et
puis y avait une petite enveloppe
alors je vais vous montrer très
rapidement avec un trio très sympathique
de la part de google bonjour nous sommes
ravis de vous présenter les toutes
dernières nouveautés de google et nous
avons pour mission de proposer à tous
des produits google plus toujours plus
utile commander derrière bref moi c'est
un peu le truc ça c'est plutôt sympa
l'ambiance heures du salon naissent
découvrez vos nouvelles enceintes nest
audio plutôt intéressant une fois de
plus un produit qui orienté musique
orienté découverte et nous va se
regarder ça tout de suite c'est bien
évidemment un produit fabriqué par
google
la boîte est loin derrière et on se
concentre ici avec ses deux enceintes
alors on va s'amorcer avant de boxing on
va regarder un petit peu comment est ce
que google nous raconte l'histoire
lorsqu'on vient elle a déballé on va
ensuite les positionner derrière on va
les écouter
tout en sachant que c'est des enceintes
donc l'idée c'est plutôt qu'à se
positionne chez vous le tarif c'est 99
euros 99 l'enceinte pouvez en acheter
deux allaient doubler le prix bien
évidemment mais vous allez augmenter
l'expérience parce qu'en plus d'avoir de
la musique un son qui a priori de
qualité mais c'est ce qu'on va valider
dans quelques instants il ya surtout
vous allez avoir de la stéréo une image
stéréoscopique
donc ça c'est bien pendant que les
positionner comme vous le souhaitez
alors là ils m'ont mis la couleur
charbon il existe deux couleurs en fait
vous avez la gale et qui est couleur
blanche et gels à charbon est ce que la
jeune galerie ou pas canon g2 charbon
c'est plutôt sain parce que j'avais
beaucoup de bien aller chez moi oh la
vache
ah ouais c'est un peu lourd on est quand
même sur une enseigne qui fait un kilo
de 1 kg de la bête c'est vraiment le
gros galets en fait c'est ça que j'ai
avec ce produit c'est très épuré très
minimaliste chez google suppose qu'on va
voir ici le bloc d'alimentation savoir
qu'effectivement et bien vous allez tout
paramétrer votre application google
applications haut dans lequel vous allez
paramétrer vos enceintes votre maison
tous vos objets connectés
je crois que en dessous c'est peut-être
avoir un petit peu de dope quelques
infos à ok c'est parti brancher le câble
d'alimentation jusque là ça va
télécharger l'application google c'est
ce que je vous disais commandes tactiles
baisser le volume play pause ok c'est
cool augmente évoluent des boutons
invisibles commande tactile ça marche la
touche micro elle est située juste ici
l'intérêt c'est que je peux venir
désactiver ou activer micro là lorsque
j'ai le petit voyant orange de ces
désactiver lorsque cela de côté le micro
est activé pour des questions de
confidentialité
c'est plutôt bien alors la
confidentialité on peut aller beaucoup
plus loin vous avez cas par exemple dire
à google docs et google
supprimons historiques comme ça va
supprimer tout votre historique de
recherche et après vous et toutes les
infos tous les messages pour vous
apprendre un peu à venir l'utiliser
c'est vraiment extrêmement minimaliste à
tous qu'on va retrouver ici à
l'intérieur de cette boîte quelques
infos essentielles donc ce qu'on va
faire tout de suite c'est qu'on va
s'installer
on va se regarder laissez moi le
paramétrer je vais vous montrer comment
ça s'installe dans l'application vous
allez voir c'est vraiment très simple
alors je n'ai pas utilisé elle donc pas
vous dire exactement mais je connais
google je connais les produits google
pour hausse extrêmement important la
simplicité d'utilisation pour que tout
un chacun puisse avoir des objets
connectés très facilement chez soi dont
je ne doute pas que ce soit très simple
on va le regarder néanmoins ensemble
laissez moi le temps de faire un petit
club de quelques secondes et on revient
nous voilà donc dans la partie
installations alors attendez j'ai ici
mais câble déjà il faut commencer par
les branches et d'un point de vue
purement électrique
la toute première enceinte là est la
deuxième enceinte je vais dans mon
application google com alors moi c'est
ici c'est dans maison ok donc là j'ai
configuré deux appareils je clique
je choisis dans quelle maison joué les
maîtres recherche d'appareils nest audio
nest audio voyez ils connaissent toutes
les deux on va commencer par la première
connexion en est audio à j'ai entendu le
son ouïe aidez nous améliorer en est oui
où se trouve pour l'instant on va se
dire on est dans le studio nom de
l'appareil
neste audio 1 il faut bien évidemment
que vous ayez un compte google il faut
que vous ayez à créer votre maison dans
votre application
c'est très simple à faire très
honnêtement et ensuite vous venez
l'ajouter dans la pièce que vous
souhaitez google vous prend par la main
pour l'installation vraiment y'a rien de
bien compliqué là dessus une fois que
vos deux enceintes sont connectés à
votre application
eh bien il vous suffit qu à les relier
ensemble mais juste avant de les relier
ensemble pour avoir une paire stéréo je
vais vous montrer un peu les différents
boutons là je les couche est directement
sur la table en face c'est la même que
vous avez là debout mais qui est couché
donc vous avez bien au centre un bouton
play pause sur la droite
c'est toute la partie on montait leçons
et sur toute la partie gauche c'est la
partie baisse elles sont donc là c'est
toute la partie pour l'enceinte
maintenant que vous montrez pour la
partie de l'application vous allez voir
c'est extrêmement simple également dans
votre application vous avez vos deux en
simple vous cliquez par exemple sur la
une et vous allez en haut là dans la
petite roue crantée et vous allez dans
paire d'enceintes et d'en perdre au sein
du pouvoir créer une paire stéréo
donc je vois que ma première up et à
gauche veulent associer avec ma deuxième
suivant partie gauche de la pièce pour
celle là est l'hôte ce sera la partie
droite je les associe toutes les deux à
mon studio nest audio stéréo et la
méduse enceintes sont associés en stéréo
et ça c'est vraiment cool
et déjà c'est beaucoup plus large tout
est installé j'ai mes deux enceintes qui
sont là il me reste plus qu'à vous
mettre un petit peu ce sont pour vous
puissiez vous rendre compte je casse du
contenu depuis mon mac comme ça vous
pouvez écouter regarder ça alors là je
vous les aimez un peu proche inscrits
pour l'image stéréo c'est pas trop ça
faudrait les écarter davantage voyez que
je vienne vraiment moi me positionner un
peu au milieu pour avoir vraiment
l'image stéréoscopique
mais c'est assez bluffant quand même ils
savent faire quand même chez google à
des enceintes qui marche plutôt pas mal
on a dans chaque enceinte
boomer qui viens vous apporter peut être
grave de 75 mm et un tweeter de 19 mm
boomer sur le bas twitter sur l'eau si
vous voulez vérifier je vous invite à
les acheter à les ouvrir comme ça vous
verrez tout par vous même vous avez
également trois micros l'ont portée pour
pouvoir lui dire ok google quelle heure
est il il est 14h30 de ce que nous
annonce google sait qu'on va avoir 75 %
de volume sonore en plus et 50% de
graver plus intense que ce qu'on avait
avant avec l'enceinte google aum
on aura donc une meilleure qualité
sonore on aura beaucoup plus de
puissance
on va pousser le son à fond
[Musique]
donc mes voisins de me déteste je baisse
le son vous avez quand même vachement de
puissance sonore c'est assez clair ça
que j'aime bien en fait on retrouve
vraiment cette clarté c'est précis et à
la fois beaucoup de rondeur des
enceintes que vous peut utiliser dans
votre espace de vie principale soit
faire une image stéréoscopique
soyez dissocier vous aurez deux source
mono ses enfants il fonctionne avec du
bluetooth 5.0 elles viennent se
connecter directement à votre réseau
wifi ça je voulais montrer lorsque vous
venez la configurer vous pouvez venir
casser tout ce que vous voulez tout ce
qui est qu à stable et vous le voyez
notamment ici depuis mon navigateur
google chrome qui dit enceinte connecter
des musiques bien évidemment mais on
peut aller beaucoup plus loin et c'est
tout l'intérêt parce que derrière vous
élevez tout google google assistant
google qui est là pour vous rendre des
services aussi bien pour connaître votre
agenda que pour ajouter un produit à
votre liste de courses pour lancer un
minuteur pour avoir une information pour
passer un coup de fil pour pouvoir
joindre quelqu'un très facilement pour
connaître la météo pour écouter ses
podcasts pour lancer une alarme en fait
tout ce qu'on pouvait faire avec google
vous pouvez le faire avec ces enceintes
donc si vous êtes utilisateurs de google
vous n'allez absolument pas être
dépaysés bien évidemment votre
application google phone vous pouvez la
voir sur ios mais également sur android
ce que j'ai trouvé intéressant là dedans
c'est que google vient renouveler sa
gamme d'enceintes avec ces nouvelles
naissent qui sont très sympa moi j'aime
bien le design envoyée c'est un objet
qui est très déco chez soi une qualité
sonore qui est plutôt bien maîtrisé la
part de google
tous les services google intègre et
autant vous dire que je trouve que c'est
un produit qui est vraiment bien alors
ce que je veux dire préconisé la danse
effectivement de les utiliser par deux
pour avoir cette fameuse image
stéréoscopique parce que c'est souvent
ce qu'on va venir reprocher à des
enceintes notamment comme les google
laisse mini est bien c'est qu'on a
uniquement une image mono en nappage
d'image stéréo pour avoir une image
stéréo il vous en faut des heures pouvez
également acheter deux enceintes de
google n'est ce mini pour avoir une
image stéréo mais pour profiter d'une
meilleure qualité sonore
mieux vaut avoir de haut parleurs à
l'intérieur twitter boomer que c'est ce
qu'on a ici
autant vous dire que là on a un son
qualité un son qui puissant avec tous
les services google intègre et moi vous
ça plutôt pas mal
a vous de me dire vous ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire qu'est ce
que vous pensez de cette enceinte
google nest audio est-ce qu'elle
pourrait vous tentez d'ailleurs ce
qu'elle vous tente vous unit tous les
liens en bas dans la description dites
moi tout ça sur ce on retrouve
extrêmement rapidement pour continuer à
parler texte parce que oui il ya plein
de choses à raconter et la prochaine
fois que je vous parlerai 25 google
et bien on parlera de maison connectée
et on fera un tour complet de la maison
et on verra de quelle manière google
vous aident avec votre maison connectée
et vous allez voir c'est vachement bien
surtout moi j'utilise tous les jours et
puis là j'ai un bon petit moment que je
vous embrasse nous ont beaucoup d'amour
qui a très vite ciao à
à
[Applaudissements]